oh how fun now it's time for a WTF what
the faala joining me now Jimmy faal his
standup special they're just jokes drops
tomorrow on Fox Nation boom hey Jimmy I
came back from vacation just for you
because I know that people have been
waiting for this for a while it's the
Steamboat Willie version of Mickey Mouse
becoming part of the public domain and
which means that other versions uh can
be made without violating copyright
watch
[Music]
where the hell did he
go Jason meets Jason meets Steamboat
Willie slasher Jimmy God they're out of
ideas in Hollywood yeah are they ever
but you have to understand this is a
woke Disney World where this movie takes
place so Mickey is coming to kill you
cuz you misgendered somebody it's a
whole different park now Laura now
they've got Peter panexual and Snow
White in the 7 Ines it's a different
Disney okay whether you're watching at
the movies or you're going to the park I
mean as a parent wasn't that the
original Disney horror film just the
fact that they're charging you 3850 for
a hot pretzel I'm still paying interest
on an ice cream cone I bought in 2011
it's not pretty don't you love how on
all the Rascal scooters at Disney they
have all of the attachments so you can
put the you know the 24 o cocacola and
then the you know the coated fried it's
there's like a little platform of food
that you can choose from most of Disney
nowadays is just fat people on scooters
eating turkey legs they just I almost
got hit by one of no you don't even go
on rides you just dodge the fat people
now no you're right about that I've been
there it's scary now Jimmy the next clip
is uh from Fortune's most powerful women
Summit in October shocking I wasn't
there but um it's going viral now for
some reason well here's Lieutenant
Colonel Brie Fram from the US space
force inclusion is a national security
imperative we fight today and we are
going to fight in the future using brain
power and if that brain just happens to
be in a trans body you should want them
all serving alongside
me Jimmy space can be anti-trans you
know that right listen man we we laugh
cuz it's a coping mechanism but the way
we're going Laura 20 years from now
we're going to have a military that's
rolling on to the battlefield in solar
powered tanks with coexist bumper
stickers on the back and we're going to
lose every war and they're all going to
come home with a trophy good gosh this
is
terrifying Jimmy when you see the
coexist bumper stickers and we see them
a lot here in California they're they're
usually they're usually kind of driven
and cars driven by women you know of a
certain age and usually I don't know
long kind of frizzled hair and usually a
big floppy dog in the back but what do
do you stay away from them or do you
engage them because maybe they're fun to
talk to no no I dodged them I just had
this issue I was up in Vermont and a cop
Dro stopped me yeah cop stopped me for
driving without a Subaru it was a big
deal I was in big trouble and I didn't
have a hate has no home here sticker on
the back the irony of those people oh no
that's the other one hate has no home
love the most hateful people ever put
those bumper stickers on their car it's
like we love we love migrants we have
you know the lawn sign people they put
the we love migrants we love all
languages we love trans and then at the
end they but you know we really don't
like the rest of you people in the
country anyone who disagrees with us we
hate oh my God if you have a lawn sign
that's not the best Jimmy have you ever
been skiing uh yes I'd like to you are
you a good skier no I'm better in the
lodge my Lodge game is on point but I'll
ski I'll
hang yeah well Sam Sam says I'm not
allowed to ski anymore because last time
I was in this studio I had my leg up
with like packs of ice on it was like
you an ice machine you could hear it
humming in the background and I so I
decided just to annoy my staff I decided
to go skiing again you can see my kids
and Kate Kate lair's in the front my old
assistant and we didn't have that ski
instructor he somehow barge into our
photo but Jimmy great to see you uh
thanks for thanks for joining us hey
Sean Hannity here hey here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else